how are you feeling sitting on my sofa
for the first time after six days of
being in bed being you know given the
honor and the privilege of becoming the
deputy leader of the Labour Party which
is historic party for me that has done
so much to help me me certainly get on
in life and and then seeing that but
actually just been physically locked
down in in my room and looking changing
around me so it was very strange and
surreal and you believe that you have
had cope at 19 and how is it hate you
because we know of course it affects
different people in different ways
I have a dry throat to begin with and
then I come down with a temperature
which my temperature was around 39 which
is very high and I had a headache
I felt very unwell and the fatigue I
cannot describe the fatigue I'm normally
a very healthy hyperactive person I only
sleep a few hours at night but I was
literally flawed and in my bed and
breathless if that like had run upstairs
even though it's not actually physically
moved than you are so it was very
debilitating and the government's right
to give the advice that we should stay
at home where possible and protect
people from this virus because it is
incredibly difficult we know that
there's been people that lost lives and
even fit and healthy people so we should
all take the warning to the government
of giving us we heard from at Hancock
earlier on the program I think he was
very strong saying that sunbathing was
against the rules that it was
unbelievable to see a minority of people
breaking the lock down you and the Matt
Hancock side of the argument or do you
have a bit more sympathy for people who
might be in crowd of accommodation with
a couple of kids wanting to catch a few
rays well it's alright for people who
have got big houses and huge back
gardens to say that but actually if
you're stuck in adequate accommodation
you've got no back out and you've got
nowhere to go and you're all on on top
of each other quite literally then I
think people should do social distance
distance in and should and should keep
their distance but also be reasonable
and proportionate about that and
the point that Matt Hancock after seven
days of having the virus went out when
the World Health Organization I've said
that you should self isolate for 14 days
I'm going to exercise that and I think
it's right that we do that because I
cannot stress enough decent the severity
of the symptoms that I've suffered as
you can tell by our breath with a I'm
still now and I'm a day nine day ten so
I think the government really need to
give that clarity and continue to
support people doing the right thing and
there's a number of concerns I have
around that we still don't have the
protective equipment for our frontline
staff we still have problems making sure
that businesses can do the right thing
and that employers employees can do the
right thing and be asked that at your
sick paid is not adequate enough and
we're not testing nowhere near tested
you know and it's a blunt tool to keep
us all at home and that's not going to
be able to continue long term so
therefore the government have to start
testing and making sure that we're
tracking this virus and tracing it and
doing what the World Health Organization
in other countries that are successful
in getting rid of this virus we've got
to lead and make sure that we're doing
the right thing and Kirsten has said
that labor is going to engage
constructively with the government on
this he's already agreed for meeting or
virtual meeting feel like with Boris
Johnson but it's quite contrast with
what Jeremy Corbyn said a few days ago
which is it's the duty of opposition
parties to hold the government to
account if everybody got together and
said we're all absolutely in this
together
that's negation of what our democratic
society is about so who do you think is
right there I think they both have some
very valid points now I don't think it
was conflicting what case Dalma said and
he's absolutely right is that we should
work constructively in the national
interest this is an extraordinary time
of crisis and I understand that and I
understand the difficulty that the
government have but we are in opposition
and there are things that the government
I believe are getting wrong like testing
they've gone against what the
international world are doing and these
questions about that and the government
have to be open and honest about that
because the public have put a huge
amount of trust in them and we will work
constructively with the government
because we've got the same aim of saving
lives and getting back to normal as soon
as we possibly can but also
we've got this absolute responsibility
to push the government where we think
they're not doing things correctly and
we'll do that constructively and I think
that's our role over these next couple
of weeks is to set out our vision to
listen to the public to earn their trust
and respect back as a political party
but also to work with the government
where we can but also highlight where we
think the government's failing and it's
failing at the moment in particular on
testing on protecting our frontline
staff and giving businesses and
employees the opportunity to do the
right thing when they're asking them to
self isolate now I want to us a little
bit about the future the Labour Party
looking forward you of course just
become the new deputy leader
Kirstin becoming the new leader he said
of labour we will change but of course
saying that the party needs to change is
the easy that really working out how it
needs to change is the more complicated
part of that so how do you think the
labour needs to change well I think it's
been you know first of all we have to
listen to our voters we can't just turn
inwards on each other and talk to
ourselves and yes we are one of the
largest parties in Europe but we've also
got to listen to what people are saying
to us and do the right thing by them you
know we didn't trust us they thought
that we didn't deal with anti-semitism
we've let down the Jewish community on
that we've got to earn the trust and
respect back on the issue but I also
think on a number of other issues they
wasn't convinced and you know the world
is changing around us now a lot of the
policies that Jeremy Corbyn advocated
the government that haven't emotion
we've seen the inadequacies in terms of
the funding for social care and for our
NHS and our public services and for our
welfare state so many people are falling
through the net at the moment and the
government have to start now
implementing some of the things that
Jeremy Corbyn advocated so I don't think
it's there you know Jeremy Corbyn versus
Kearse arm it's about our labor values
and making sure that we look after
everyone in society which is what our
priority should be now and just before
we spoke to you we also talked to Alan
Johnson the former health secretary who
didn't really hold back in his
assessment of jeremy corbyn's leadership
dreadful and awful is what he says and
he also said that labour needs to get
rid of the cult I think he was referring
to momentum there
is he right I think labour needs to get
away from any form of you know putting
people in factional boxes no Blair is
and carbon ISM brownies and all of that
has to go where a labor family and
families have difference of opinions and
I agree with Ellen on that that we do
have constructive disagreements at times
but that should be welcomed in our party
that people can agree to disagree but
also that we move forward as a
collective with our same aims and values
and I think Jeremy Corbyn really took
the party forward you know he talks
about anti austerity he talks about
investing in our public services which
this government is having to do now so I
think he would right to do that and I
think we owe Jeremy that a gratitude
with that but we've also got to
recognize that our failings and we
failed at the last general election what
we failed for for general elections
we've not won a general election for a
very long time so therefore we've got to
listen to the voters and we've got to
respect back and I want to do that and
I'm sure that under cares leadership
working with all of our political
movement we can do that together ok and
now we are running out time so just a
quick one for me please and we'll be
seeing the new shadow cabinet drawer
quite soon you're hoping to hang onto
your role as shadow education secretary
immensely proud serve Jeremy Corbyn as
the shadow education secretary and to
develop a national education service I'm
committed even as deputy leader to make
sure that happens in whatever guys that
is because I think it's it's important
that we have that and I hope that that
will be Jeremy's legacy when we go into
government and you know Joe I'm sure
Kerr will make sure all talents are in
our shadow cabinet and I think it's time
now for us to come together to get the
best of the best out there on the front
working constructively where possible
with the government or pushing forward
to end this coronavirus crisis as soon
as possible and get like working again
for people of this country and then just
finally you back to your friend and
flatmate Rebecca long Bailey for the
leadership we disappointed that she lost
and have you spoken since maybe a quick
chat over zoom or something
the challenging for me because I was
still feeling very unwell and had lots
to do and today's my first day really
that I've been up an owl I don't want to
thank everyone for their good wishes
throughout this process but I think
we're back on Bailey has a huge amount
to offer the party I'm incredibly proud
of her and I'm incredibly proud to be
honoured and given the privilege to
serve on their cameras the deputy leader
of the Labour Party I don't want to
prove to everyone that I can do that and
I can get us into government